we begin in beijing with the winter
olympics due to open later in the week
the united states and other nations are
staging a diplomatic boycott of the
event in protest at china's human rights
record while growing numbers of covet 19
cases are also worrying athletes and
officials beijing insists the games will
be safe
arrival at the airport in beijing
chinese workers in protective gear
welcome the incoming olympic teams and
their baggage
then it's a pcr test before a trip to
the venues in the olympic village where
similar tests are to follow on a daily
basis
caution is the watchword
china's cross-country skiers are being
shielded from foreign rivals their
norwegian coach tells us
with this team we have been staying in
china the full time for the past two
years
so
they have been extremely careful we
haven't actually competed
internationally for two years
of the foreign athletes who have already
arrived
125 have tested positive for covert 19
and have isolated it's not clear whether
they'll all get the negative test result
they need in time to compete
the opening ceremony fireworks have been
rehearsed but critics say that china is
using the pizzazz of the games to
distract from human rights abuses
so the ccp's purpose is exactly to turn
the sports arena into a stage for
political legitimacy and a tool to
whitewash all those
atrocities
but china itself boasts of its strength
and promises a safe winter olympics in
beijing
the plight of china's weaker community
and their harsh repression looms large
over the winter olympics with opposition
suppressed within china itself many are
making their voices heard elsewhere our
washington bureau chief inis poll has
met a uyghur restaurant owner in los
angeles whose father disappeared three
years ago
these mountains remind bukra are keen
very much of home
he left china six years ago to start a
new life in the u.s
everything seemed to go well until his
father who remained in china was
abruptly snatched from his home during
the night of october 25th in 2018.
his father owned one of the biggest
rigger publishing firms and arkeen
believes that his fight to protect the
wiggle language and culture was the
reason why the chinese government put
him in prison
he and our keen were best friends his
father also supported him financially in
the u.s my biggest
fear i really scared like he couldn't uh
cuddle his grand
children's
to
just cuddle with me again
that's my biggest fear
to see him again
i wish u.s government and euro
they can do more to pressure on china
about their
the genocide
after his father was detained bukra
arkhin opened a restaurant in the larger
la area he named it dullance after the
bigger region in eastern jinjan where he
grew up
one of the most popular dishes is
lachman a dish of hand-pulled noodles
the wiggle kitchen reflects the far
western area of china at the border of
kyrgyzstan and tajikistan where most of
the region's 12 million wiggers live
surprising not many people
know about vigors even there are so many
news on the media
so
like i have to attract them to
create like curiosity
then
let's throw this t-shirt i think it
helps a lot like people they ask about
vigors they google the vigors
some of his customers already know a lot
about the topic others are just about to
find out
as an american i feel a responsibility
as a conscientious consumer
to understand that the uyghurs are
inextricably connected to american
consumership and capitalism that there
are so many companies that have direct
or indirect relationships to uighur
labor
through the forced detention and forced
labor camps that the chinese are
inflicting on them and have been for so
long so i'm definitely interested in
knowing more about them and i plan to
google wigger later today
let's go to munich now and speak to
azumaritai arkhan program manager of the
world weaker congress which advocates
for weaker human rights so good to have
you with us we are just obviously days
away from the winter games in beijing
with the eyes of the world focused on
china how much attention do you think
will there be on the plight of the
weakers
we certainly hope that there will be
enough attention on the human rights
atrocities that are occurring in not
only east turkestan but also in tibet
hong kong and all across china as well
because this is a unique opportunity
when the war the world's eyes will be
focused on china and we hope that
this focus is not only going to be on
sports but also on what's happening
behind
do you feel that the ioc and elite sport
in general are indifferent to the plight
of the uyghurs
i think that um they don't necessarily
care enough to act because we did meet
with the ioc on more than one occasion
and we shared our pleas we shared our
concerns about what was happening
you know in the context of the games
what would be happening if and citing
very concrete examples such as wheeler
forced labor that might be involved in
producing olympic
olympic goods olympic uniforms and
merchandises because we know that the
ioc has contracted with chinese groups
that are um tightly linked to uber for
sabre so when we shared these concerns
there was nothing concrete that they
were willing to do to address these
human rights issues
so the ioc was not receptive to some of
your criticism do you hope that there
may be protests at the games for maybe
certain elite athletes competing in the
olympics
absolutely um i think it's really
up to the athletes to speak up um and we
expect them to do it because yes there
will be consequences as we have heard
directly from a member of the beijing
organizing committee two weeks ago
basically threatening athletes if they
wanted to speak up on certain issues but
we hope that athletes who will be the
most protected and privileged
groups of individuals
at these games will use their platforms
to speak up
and of course we know that because of
rule 50 they're not able to speak up on
the podium but we hope that they can use
opportunities during press conferences
and other occasions to bring up these
issues
a number of countries as you know high
profile countries have announced a
diplomatic boycotts ahead of the
games are you encouraged by that does it
make any difference
it is very encouraging to see because um
it sends a very clear and strong message
to beijing that uh the international
community will not uh simply watch by uh
the you know why when china is
committing a genocide and at the same
time given this prestigious platform to
host the games
so it sends a very clear message to
beijing and we believe that beijing is
feeling that pressure
otherwise they wouldn't be harassing
activists um and threatening athletes
from speaking up um and another thing
that is quite important to highlight is
that it gives our community hope
and encouragement as well
hope and encouragement but in the
meantime the chinese leadership is not
budging when it comes to its
weaker policies are these limited
boycotts emboldening in a certain sense
the chinese president to continue on
this path
i think
um this is something that's very
difficult to tell just because of the
extremely difficulty um to access to any
kind of information of what's happening
inside uh we've lost contact with our
family members um you know pretty much
every single we are living in exile
doesn't have contact so it's in in that
situation it's very difficult to see if
these policies are being um softened or
you know um or worsened
but we do know that in the recent years
the human rights situation has
deteriorated quite significantly we're
talking about a genocide
and we i think the only way to address
this is
by via multilateral action if enough
countries are pressuring china
because we we know and we've seen that
china does care about its international
reputation and and credibility despite
uh claiming otherwise
is program manager of the world weaker
congress which advocates for weaker
human rights thank you very much for
coming on and talking to us
thanks for having me